hey what's going on hey what's going on
sorry I didn't know if this thing was on
or not it's bill burr and it's time for
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
January 7 2018 what's going on how are
ya
it's [ __ ] 3:30 two in the morning and
I've slept a little bit but it just been
having a [ __ ] overtime with this
jet lag over here and you know why it is
it's because I'm not boozing okay this
one's for all you alcoholics out there
I'm [ __ ] with you people keep telling
me to go get melatonin it's a natural
way to get tired all I know is the
unnatural way to get type tired which
was what I always did was just the first
night I tried to stay up and then I go
out and I would just go get I'd go booze
I have a poor [ __ ] stiff drinks and
just come home and pass out and then I
start to get acclimated to their time
I'd have to do that about three nights
in a row and then I was fine so whatever
I just been so I got to do this [ __ ]
podcast cuz today I'm getting on a plane
and I'm flying to Estonia to do one show
tonight I'm very excited about it I
googled some pictures first of all
Estonia Jesus Christ what a badass flag
that's one of those things that I
collect I don't buy a lot of touristy
[ __ ] so I just get those little flags so
I got to make sure I get time to go down
and pick one of those up then I got
Latvia the next day this is the part of
the tour where I start going to all
these places I've never been to as far
as country's goes but the last two
nights I started in Cologne I'd been
there before we did Munich on Saturday
and yesterday we did off and back often
Bach and I just been a [ __ ] great
time being over here with virzi sorry my
voice is going dude you know I'm trying
to make sure I have good shows and I
don't know
what the [ __ ] I did to it but uh
yesterday I should say Saturday and
Sunday we had two shows Munich to an
often buck and the first [ __ ] show
was like at 3:30 p.m. this is what kills
me I've never in my career that I can
really remember ever gone on stage like
that I mean at that time I think maybe
one time I was doing hilarious in
Cleveland and I did an afternoon show
but I think that was it like four or
five I don't know just 3:30 was [ __ ]
weird but I gotta tell you
the crowd was unbelievable Munich crowds
were [ __ ] ridiculous
I mean they've all been great but they
were just like we were in like just I
just sort of God that felt like I was in
like a little barn and it was like
snowing out and I had to walk from the
green room back outside into the snow
and then back into the venue when I was
just like these [ __ ] are trying
to get me sick so I might coat on my big
stupid pom-pom hat that I got in Finland
way back in the day which has been
saving my ass
that the vitamin C packets and both
shows the crowds were just crazy good
and in between shows I ran around trying
to find my daughter some sneakers some
cool sneakers up I found this store
called early somebody told me about and
we drove over there and I bought a
couple pairs two sneakers I got to the
forest gump once you know the classic
Nike Cortez and I made sure that I got
the the velcro straps so she can get a
little fat [ __ ] toddler feet in there
you know but it's pretty [ __ ] cool
because in the middle of the city they
had this giant just giant wall going her
you know I didn't see how could we just
literally drove by it and it was the
original wall of the city for like back
in the day when there was just like you
know was a free-for-all
you just sit in your village and all of
a sudden some [ __ ] [ __ ] would
just show up and just start murdering
the men and raping the women and like
[ __ ] on fire and it was just like like
that's what people did back then like
that was like a [ __ ]
like something that someone aspired to
they aspired to rape and pillage and he
just [ __ ] lunatic [ __ ] so these
people you know wanted to survive so
they would build these giant walls I
guess around their [ __ ] villages and
then someone's trying to tell me Attila
the Hun used to save the bodies from the
previous village and then he'd sneak up
on a village he'd light the bodies on
fire and then with like a catapult would
start shooting them into the [ __ ]
village he wanted to attack like you
just sitting there chilling out and join
yourself and like all of a sudden you
know I don't know what was a job back
then some [ __ ] coppersmith comes
through the top of your [ __ ] little
Hut they're on fire and lands on your
goddamn dinner table and that that was
that was the first sign that your life
was gonna [ __ ] change i mean jesus
[ __ ] christ that's crazy and i don't
know what it is about europe maybe
because i watched all this [ __ ] about
world war ii and you know and a lot of
you know american history they don't
give a [ __ ] about you know the whole
curriculum was designed by white
descendents from europe so that's all we
[ __ ] talked about so you just know
certain [ __ ] of course they you know
they dance around a lot of [ __ ] but as
i've been hoping that when we took the
train from [ __ ] munich up to
Offenbach they were like next stop like
Nurenberg and I'm like Nurenberg like
Nuremberg trials for some reason I
thought that that was those trials were
in France and now that I'm getting
exposed a little more to the German
language I'm like well obviously that's
not a [ __ ] French city so I'm on the
train and I'm text and virzi to be like
- this is where they [ __ ] tried all
the Nazis the SS and the Gestapo and
[ __ ] after World War two and they like
they'd like [ __ ] put him to death and
[ __ ] hanging him and everything and
I'm texting him and he can't [ __ ]
yeah he's not getting the service so
Mike mercy mercy he looks up you know
he's a couple seats away you know but
out of the respect for German people I
would be like hey this is where they
[ __ ] killed all the Nazis after World
War two I walked over to him and I
started to say it but because I'm
speaking English people just look at him
like oh there's a [ __ ] American let's
judge him is he fat is he breathing
through his mouth
you know is he loud so I just literally
had to show him the text and I'm sitting
here you know like when you go to
[ __ ] Berlin that's where Hitler
killed himself
and part of his bunker still exists I
don't even they [ __ ] destroyed most
of it the Soviets did and then they
built just like an apartment building
around it you know it's like Los Angeles
how they do that [ __ ] they just knock
[ __ ] down and they don't give a [ __ ]
what happened and I get it cuz the guy
was so [ __ ] evil but like I'm just a
cloud so [ __ ] crazy that people just
walk amongst all of this [ __ ]
and then I was like wait a minute I live
in the United States of America I go
down south all the time I can't imagine
what the [ __ ] happened right where I'm
sitting when I'm sitting in a [ __ ]
Waffle House like if that used to be
like a plantation or some slave was
running away and they got caught and God
knows what the [ __ ] happened forget
about the Native Americans so I was like
the light of [ __ ] do I only think about
that [ __ ]
you know like every time I go to Paris
like when I look at this Sean's alizée
that [ __ ] Street I just pictured when
the Nazis [ __ ] paraded up the damn
thing when they occupied their country
and when the Allied forces when they
took it back I mean all the French
ladies banged a bunch of Americans
evidently how come I don't think of that
[ __ ] my own country it's just cuz cuz I
grew up there it's [ __ ] I almost
thought that would be like a weird one
of those sci-fi [ __ ] movies slash
horror movies that I don't know if you
just if you
I get them because they kind of do it
they do it unlike light [ __ ]
like if you move into a house and
someone got murdered there in the 20s
right like let me tell you something she
I'm gonna Schleck you if I'm [ __ ] here
to here right then all of a sudden that
place is haunted but they don't like
maybe American Horror Story did it I
don't [ __ ] know i watch sports but
anyway and then then I'm reading all of
this [ __ ] and it's like about the
Nuremberg trial when I'm on the [ __ ]
train and making sure nobody's looking
over my shoulder and I'm seeing how like
they had to decide how they were gonna
it was sort of the first time I think of
World War one they tried to do it
but this is the first time they were
trying to make people pay for their
[ __ ] war crimes so you know FDR and
[ __ ] Churchill and all these guys are
trying to figure out how they're gonna
go about doing it and FDR balked at
something and then he died and then
Truman came in and it was just like well
wait a minute yeah Truman came in and
was like no we're gonna do that [ __ ] so
he must have still been at war with
Japan and then he goes and he drops two
[ __ ] nuclear weapons on [ __ ] Japan
like it was it's like they were all
[ __ ] world war criminals be sitting
there firebomb and Dresden and [ __ ]
there's like women and children down
there it's it's so I don't know that's
why I always say like to this day I
can't believe that like war is still
legal you know slash like glorified and
I mean I understand defending your
country and [ __ ] like that if there's a
[ __ ] lunatic out there but like you
know who's kidding hope you know a lot
you know there's been a lot of iffy
decisions made out there for you know
it's just a [ __ ] land grab you're
going after oil you know you you want
even want that land cuz it's it's got
some water around it I mean that's why
people go to [ __ ] war most of the
time it seems nowadays anyways but
anyways I don't know somehow that leads
to me to talking about [ __ ] thin
privilege
I follow this guy Yanis Papas on
Instagram he's like [ __ ] genius does
all these characters and stuff so I'm
always watching him Kyle Dunnigan Jeff
Richards they're like my favorite like
the [ __ ] characters they do the
[ __ ] geniuses right so I was watching
his and he posted something about it so
um well what the [ __ ] is thin privilege
I already know I have white privilege
evidently I have been privileged to like
if it was like monopoly and there was a
stretch of little properties that were
the privileged properties like I feel
like I got some of those little green
houses on a lot of them so evidently
it's a privilege to be thin rather than
a reward for having the discipline to
push yourself away from the [ __ ]
table you know and I'm not I'm not
talking about when you were a kid you
just some people have baby fat guy baby
fat I was a fat [ __ ] kid I was like
ten pounds you know when I was born I
was a big [ __ ] red Charlie Brown
looking [ __ ] baby
there's not one cute picture of me til
I'm like three and my head was literally
almost the size it is right now when I
was an adult like I literally from day
one look like I could [ __ ] up a lego
city right and uh you know but I just
used that to my advantage
I'd be on the playground of people be
[ __ ] with because my orange hair like I
just leaned on him you know like like a
boxer that just wear him out in the
early rounds and then I just [ __ ] you
know a bunch of body shots and it would
be over me with my big flabby freckled
arms and then somewhere in like junior
high I just sort of leaned out like all
of a sudden I grew a little bit and and
then I stopped growing and then I was
just a small skinny kid I kind of had it
all you know when it comes to the
bullying I was a fat kid when I was
really young then I was but I was big
and then I became small and I was skinny
and you throw it all in there I had
orange hair so it was kind of inevitable
that I was going to end up being some
sort of a [ __ ] comedian or something
I don't know what but um
anyways this then privilege said it's
like they're like people who are thin
need to [ __ ] acknowledge you know
it's up to you to realize how privileged
you are that you know people don't judge
you when you eat a cookie in public and
pump up about all this shitty psycho
like [ __ ] judge me when I put on a
pair of shorts
look at how [ __ ] white my legs are
you know these [ __ ] people you know
what it kills me about [ __ ] like that
alright I get it we shouldn't tease fat
people and make them feel bad and all
that you know it's [ __ ] immature and
it's mean I get it right but on the
other side it's like there's no there's
no burden of responsibility it's
something that's totally [ __ ] curable
and I know some people literally have
like food addictions and like it's a
psychological thing or whatever but you
know for most people who are fat it's
just you just eating too much [ __ ]
food you know and considering most of
the goddamn world is starving you know
it's just like if can you understood
that with this train of thought fat
white people in a first world nation can
literally walk around and call
themselves victims well you know I don't
know all of these [ __ ] fatties I
swear to God that's why I did that bit
on it at my last special you need to go
to some countries with that people are
like really have some problems I mean
you can even go just go on the [ __ ]
Internet read about it he can fill a
hell of a lot [ __ ] better about
yourself you know I was sitting there
you know I was getting frustrated with
being [ __ ] jet-lagged and [ __ ] and
he's 3:30 in the afternoon show is I was
like [ __ ] man now I can't [ __ ] sleep
and I was like feeling like I was a
zombie and I was getting all grumpy and
[ __ ] and then I could go on the internet
and I'm like wait a minute
okay so if Nuremburg here where was our
switch oh I gotta say right the
concentration camp place right and it
turns out it's in Poland I was like well
I don't have the time it's gonna be too
far away so I kind of googled some
[ __ ] pictures of it and [ __ ] and I
looked at it
I was like oh my god I could never
[ __ ] go there I mean literally like
your [ __ ] blood runs cold like
looking at this [ __ ] then they had like
you know pictures of like piles of like
kids shoes and [ __ ] and I'm literally
buying shoes for my kid and I'm just
like going am I really bitching that I
have a 3:30 [ __ ] show kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] am i right I think
people eatin [ __ ] hot fudge sundaes
ought to do that every once in a while
you know what I mean they better look up
a bunch of starvin [ __ ] kids in the
middle of nowhere not even in the middle
of nowhere in the middle of where the
world for whatever could reason
considers nowhere before you sit there
and try to like figure out a new way to
try and [ __ ] up somebody's career
because that's gonna be another thing
this is such a weird [ __ ] time of so
many goddamn people like they just keep
trying to like I keep looking at like a
bike race like they try to get behind
somebody who has like a legitimate
complaint like I gotta be honest with
you the fact that white women can
[ __ ] use the term white male
privilege and they're like a white woman
the United States of America the fact
that they can somehow hop on the other
side of the fence as some sort of like
you know underprivileged group and I'm
not saying that you know they don't get
less than white males but it's just like
should I really be listening to your
complaints next are you really gonna be
first in line you would actually have
white privilege when it comes to
complaining because people are gonna pay
attention to your [ __ ] first even though
you suffer in the least right as far as
my complete lack of research goes as far
as me babbling here it's not good for
the goddamn morning
you don't really like opens I'm not
waking somebody up mumbling here anyways
so I guess that's the latest thing that
can get you to not [ __ ] I don't know
sell some tickets on the road or [ __ ]
huh you know host an awards show like
whatever the [ __ ] we're gonna do you
know you don't blows my mind about that
whole award show scandal is I just love
how whatever was said was said around
and all these adults who were well old
enough
well old enough were plenty old enough
to have gotten offended back then and
made a big stink and for some reason it
doesn't [ __ ] come out it's almost
like they get you on something like
right hold on to that card you know what
I mean like they're playing granny
[ __ ] water and then they wait till
you get something big enough that's
gonna shine a light in that cause and
then they come back and they [ __ ] try
and slam it down on the [ __ ] table I
was out of the country but as far as
what I read Ellen DeGeneres is cool in
my book for the rest of [ __ ] time you
know and I thought whatever she was
trying to do was a [ __ ] is the way to go
about stuff like that well you just
don't try to [ __ ] destroy somebody
you try to get him see your point try to
get people on your side to be hey give
this person another chance you have it
be open like that you open it up to a
discussion and then people just watch it
and learn some [ __ ] rather than just
being like this person said this now
they can't have that now let's watch
them [ __ ] you know lose something you
know who she's just sitting there
watching for the [ __ ] entertainment
value this is one of my favorite things
to do by the way is to get on my [ __ ]
high horse here and preach and a quarter
to 4:00 in the [ __ ] morning whatever
[ __ ] time it is here all right let's
talk NFL playoffs I missed most of them
I was able to watch a little bit of that
Eagles Bears game in German which was
pretty cool because they kept enough for
the English word that I was able to you
know kind of know what the [ __ ] they
were talking about and I know
everybody's gonna get on the Bears
kicker but can somebody please explain
to me why the [ __ ] you go for a
two-point conversion when the Bears did
that why not just [ __ ] kick the
goddamn thing and then he end up losing
by one John Madden my entire [ __ ]
life
said you take the points you take the
points you take the points those extra
points come back to haunt you and I know
this guy I missed that I guess he hit
him
a number of [ __ ] gold posting hit the
chronic old post on the crossbar in the
last one I watched the highlights but
why the [ __ ] you going for two points
there makes just you know well choose
you're only up by two you're acting like
it's the end of the game with the
[ __ ] two minutes to go
there's a whole bunch of time left and I
forget when it happened the end of the
third quarter beginning the fourth
quarter but there was plenty of [ __ ]
time where it's a complete non-factor
just take that extra [ __ ] point just
take the [ __ ] thing and then see
where the [ __ ] you are with the last
five minutes then you start playing that
game
you know everybody's going like Patrick
wanna like pulling the [ __ ] goalie
with like 10 minutes left in the game
which for some reason actually worked
for him so congratulations to to the
eagle to Nick Falls man yeah but by the
way though that mentor Biscay man had a
trip risk he's a useiess name we had a
[ __ ] break game through for over 300
yards I thought he was like really
accurate and he was dealing with like
that the defending Super Bowl champions
that though he was great through Nick
Foles is like that guy you know like I
just [ __ ] delivers oh my god Pete
Carroll Jesus Christ the poor [ __ ]
bastard
the poor [ __ ] bastard man he's
getting a ton of [ __ ] and Seattle I
guess they thought he ran the ball too
much and I don't know what happened that
field goal kicker got [ __ ] hurts and
then they have their punter there and he
has to do an onside kick like why didn't
he just do what they all do just stick
it on the tee and then he kicked the
ball in a downward motion on the upper
third of the [ __ ] ball so it pops up
in the air the guy just be [ __ ] just
[ __ ] basically lobbed it down the
field that you know something if Pete
Carroll never won a Super Bowl and they
were gonna make a statue of him it would
be him with his hands on his [ __ ]
knees just looking down at the ground in
pain he's sort of the Urban Meyer of NFL
coaches you know in that they both won
they just have that [ __ ] they just
have that that's soul-crushing whenever
I see him do that you know that reminds
me of it reminds me of Carl Yastrzemski
when he back when he's backing up to the
wall when Bucky Dent hit that three-run
homer and you just saw his legs buckle
it just reminds me of that every time I
see that [ __ ] so I don't know my
condolences I don't usually have
condolences to Seattle fans but I don't
know if the rivalries kind of died down
youth football fans I feel free I've
been there and all that [ __ ]
congratulations San Diego Chargers and I
forget who played the last game all the
Colts I guess the Colts look good in
Andrew Luck he's back which is great
[Music]
other than that I haven't been [ __ ]
doing anything fair I should probably do
some of these reads here this podcast
might be a little short cuz I have to
get up go to the airport already up
alright oh look who's here I can't do
this read justice everybody I apologize
it's old zip recruiter you know what's
smart figuring out who you need to hire
to take care of your business to take
your business to the next level in 2019
you know what else is mad stat in the
new year off strong by going to zip
recruiter dot-com / / to hire the right
[ __ ] people
unlike other jobs I wonder if now when
you go to hire the right people they
should add to zip recruiter it also goes
through all your earrin all the tweets
you've ever sent out to make sure
someone's not gonna be like you know I
wanted to rent a car from this person
and then they said this tweet in 2009
making fun of people with ugly feet I
have feet that are they wouldn't say
ugly how would they say it I don't know
visually challenged
unlike other job sites zip recruiting
finds qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and actively invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast
that's why zip
what recruiter yeah said German version
is rated number one by employers in the
US this rating comes from hiring sites
on trust pilot with over 1000 reviews
and right now my listeners can't get the
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web site zip recruited comm / / if you
love this show show you support to it
and zip recruiter by going to zip
recruit comm / Burpee you are our that
zip recruit comm / / hot so my voice is
going out trying to the German guard in
every movie is it recruit the smartest
way to hire all right policy genius
getting life insurance is one of the
more intimidating parts of becoming a
full-fledged adult it's not that bad if
you have kids it's weird if you get it
and you just have your wife you know
because then you like is this bet you're
gonna kill me once you have the kid you
like I want them to be all right sorry I
watch a lot of those [ __ ] first 48
and it always comes down you know first
tonight murder is so much if it comes
down to life insurance
I might not selling this right well
right now I don't think I am there are
so many options it's hard to know where
to start but making sure your family is
financially protected is too important
to avoid this is what you do once you
get life insurance
you just sort of monitor your wife's
laptop or your husband's if they're
checking out like you know how to
dispose of a body or they check it out
when the tides go in and out then I
think you might want to put a little
Mendham to your policy so policy genius
creates a website that makes it easy for
you to compare quotes and get advice and
get covered without extra fees or
Commission sales agent motivate your
audience talk about your experience with
the product / service I've never used it
but I got life insurance and now
whenever I hit turbulence when I'm
flying or whatever I don't worry about
it cuz I'm like well you know what as
much as they're gonna miss me it's you
know they're gonna be they're gonna be
alright
and the house won't be as loud choose
one to to copy points to rotate into
your spot alright I'll read the first
two policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford from there you can apply online
and the advisors that policy genius will
handle all the red tape they leave and
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company it's all part of their best
price guarantee that's great because
it's a [ __ ] show trying to find the
right one if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past try
starting your search at policy genius
com in minutes you can compare quotes
and apply you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now
policy genius the easiest way to compare
and buy life insurance now [ __ ] how am I
gonna do this read justice with my voice
here honey
you probably heard me talk about honey
the free browser extension that
automatically helps me save money on all
my favorite sites but did you know that
honey even makes amazon better with
million entered [ __ ] Amazon those
[ __ ] [ __ ] those [ __ ] they throw
it over the fence they consider it
delivered there's no return address
you never can figure out who the [ __ ]
sent it to you it's a [ __ ] nightmare
with millions of sellers on Amazon
offering the same products how do you
know if you're really getting the best
price how the [ __ ] do you know if it was
delivered there's no [ __ ] phone call
you got to bring it back down to a shop
and they're just little you know close
we could tell it was delivered we
confirmed it
that's where honey comes in what cuz the
[ __ ] driver said it was confirmed
honey automatically goes to wear to work
whenever I shop on Amazon I herded this
other [ __ ] on Amazon it's [ __ ] and I
never got it I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is it compares the presents it's like
the worst advertising read ever it
compares the prices of every seller that
carries the item I want honey even
factors in shipping sales tax and Amazon
Prime status to make sure I'm getting
the lowest price it shows me the best
delivery time even if Amazon doesn't
it's like having my very own personal
shopping assistant course Amazon does if
you can't [ __ ] get anybody on the
phone more than 10 million people are
using honey
to save money honey and so has over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
Google maybe I need honey so Amazon will
work better for me five star reviews on
the Google Chrome store Time magazine
says it's basically free money so the
next time you're in the world's biggest
marketplace looking for the best deals
treat yourself to the free upgrade that
makes Amazon better add honey for free
at join honeycomb / bird that's join
honey calm / burn that's hilarious I'm
making fun of Amazon and everything that
they don't do well honey actually fixes
it so in a way I was selling it because
God knows we're all still gonna use
Amazon right alright
last really a my bookie how the [ __ ] he
doing huh are you doing you [ __ ]
degenerate NFL playoffs are here and
it's time to get into the edge with my
bookie don't be that guy with no rooting
interest as your relatives or friends
sit around watching the game not this
year when the 53rd Super Bowl is around
the corner is it really 53 holy I've
been watching since Super Bowl 12
[ __ ] it's real it really is the most
wonderful time of year make sure you're
ready for the daily action by signing up
at my bookie today they pay fast when
you win ownership really cares about
good customer service and they offer the
craziest props when you bet it's just as
important as who you're betting on a way
where you bet is just as important as
who you're betting on and if you wanted
to make money during the bowl season you
got to go to my bookie I trust them but
you don't have to take my word for it
check them out for yourself join now and
my bookie will offer you a 50% deposit
bonus to make sure you have a nice
bankroll nice [ __ ] bankroll football
season use the promo code burr when you
deposit to activate the offer that's
promo code birth and my bookie on a
[ __ ] door you pay you when you get
paid
alright where am I have you 30 [ __ ]
minutes [ __ ] I hope I'm not getting sick
here how much [ __ ] vitamin C do you
have to take you know
let me grab one of these goddamn packets
yeah I'll drink one now dude this
[ __ ] hotel I can't figure out I can't
figure out how to turn on
[ __ ] heat you know but I the one of
the thing the only thing I hate more
than not being able to turn it on on the
[ __ ] he is having to crawl down to
the front desk and then they gotta send
somebody up I just I thought I would
rather sit here and get sick here we go
a little bit of [ __ ] offenbach
bottled water I mean I can get Seltzer's
on my podcast to advertise a little
vitamin C packet here this is how you do
it
hey did anybody else on Twitter's see
that hilarious little I don't is it a
gift is that it was a picture I don't
know what the [ __ ] he call it
you know Bell Biv DeVoe somebody made
one that was Bell Biv and will him
default so his Bell Biv default and
that's the kind of [ __ ] that's the kind
of [ __ ] that I [ __ ] love I love that
silly [ __ ] alright there we go that
Christ Bell disturbing it with your
finger you [ __ ] animal what is wrong
with you
all right down the hatch here we go let
it stop visit all right
so anyways yeah so I ordered room
service as far as I can tell the top
three things on room service in Germany
are a hamburger Vienna schnitzel or
spaghetti and I actually when I was in
Munich I got some bean or schnitzel
which I always thought was like a
[ __ ] hot dog but I saw pork cutlet
that's breaded it was [ __ ] delicious
that's what's killing me about being
here in Germany is I haven't had time to
get like a proper German meal I've just
been traveling so much and you know I
I'm never gonna do ancestry.com but as
far as the names of my family tree I
know I am mostly German I love this [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] sausages and [ __ ] beer
and all that it kills me I'll tell you
the next time
I come here to Germany which I'm
definitely gonna do because it's been so
much fun I am gonna be beyond off the
wagon and I'm trying all these [ __ ] B
I'm gonna book myself out here in
Oktoberfest I'm gonna buy a little me
undies Oktoberfest outfit outfit and I'm
gonna [ __ ] drink my ass off but not on
this tour Oh Billy no fun it's coming up
on 50 days of just being a [ __ ]
douche bag anyways so let's plow ahead
here let's read some of these [ __ ]
things for the week just another one
about Poland all right very excited to
go to Poland - very excited to go to
Berlin all of like all the rest of this
tour it's just gonna be just a bunch of
just a bunch of [ __ ] I've never seen oh
and speaking of that guess who came out
to the show last night guess who the
[ __ ] showed up one of my favorite
drummers one of the greatest drummers in
the world Benny Greb showed up with his
lovely girlfriend
I hate naming names and everything but
everybody knows who the [ __ ] he is right
he [ __ ] I couldn't vote it's just it's
unbelievable if you're a drummer out
there and you want to see somebody who
possesses one of the rare things in
drumming which is incredible feel
passion playing from the heart
combined with ridiculous chops and the
thing that I found with drumming is when
you get those chops guys a lot of times
when they play they're between their
ears like they're in their head and they
have all this really intricate [ __ ] but
it it's disconnected to who they are as
a person
and then if you have like a groove
player you know if they go to take a
solo if they even do it's you know it's
still good because it still grooves but
it's not like the crazy I don't know I'm
just saying those guys that have those
[ __ ] insane chops where you would
think even Buddy Rich would be going
like dude what the [ __ ] you're doing
there nowadays far
drumming has come because everybody the
Internet's but basically everybody's
watching everybody everybody's jamming
learning from each other it's just so
rare to meet a guy that has his chops
and plays the way he does so he does
clinics all around the world and he's
got some DVDs out there and all in
there's no [ __ ] way that you won't be
tremendously changed for the better if
you somehow start watching his video so
it's bené bené Greb b e @ n YG r eb i
believe i'm not sure if this - I can't
[ __ ] spell anything just check them
out if you can alright anyways just
another one about Poland dear MC run
from the Sun I like that one I am
honestly thrilled that in a few days
you're gonna show up in my not so
beautiful city of Warsaw don't tell me
that well I live in a not so beautiful
city of La and I love it I like how it's
gritty and grimy and all that [ __ ] you
know sorry
check it modify time you see here mainly
because I'm okay I'm honestly thrilled
that you're gonna be in a few days and
you're gonna show up in my not so
beautiful city of Warsaw mainly because
I'm selling my house and you are so
white that you're rising the property
value whenever you arrive skies
hilarious
Oh lady let's be fair I don't want to
thin shame anybody or whatever the [ __ ]
you were talking about a but since
you're kind enough to do one of those
[ __ ] ass shows of yours I will
definitely come I like this guy's
breaking [ __ ] balls your you are gonna
love Poland as Yosef Pollard ski used to
say it's a great nation only people are
constant whole wait a minute dude is
everybody as funny as you in Poland is
this gonna be another [ __ ] country
I'd go to where I'm just like oh my god
these guys remind me the people I grew
up with I felt that in Ireland I felt it
in Scotland I felt that in India just
that dad busting chops ball breaking
[ __ ] things my tits my favorite thing
in the world anyways as for the city of
Warsaw well she's not the
of gals but let's be fair that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] went through some [ __ ]
we are watching American show so don't
worry about making your pop-culture
references we're currently watching Alf
and once we figure out why those jokes
are funny we're gonna move on to Frasier
dude can you please start doing stand-up
or something this is just all of this is
just written really [ __ ] funny you
can also consider renting a helicopter
here since it's much cheaper than the US
although polish helicopter it's just a
horse wearing a windmill hat right he
had one [ __ ] polish joke there best
wishes to your family and break your
pasty leg on this tour PS if you're
interested in soviet-bloc history God
knows I didn't learn about that when I
was growing up then you should check
comedian fries love fre easy lu v
talking about his military service in
berlin during the Cold War I will
definitely check that out and I'll send
out a link to this podcast episode here
I'll speak in which I've been having the
best time with virzi right
at first he the one thing I love about
Percy is virzi is virzi okay the way man
he was gonna be Manny Paul versus Rosa
he's over here wearing his Jordans you
know he's got his [ __ ] Nike tracksuit
on and we were in Cologne Germany did I
tell you this yet I told it on stage so
many times we're literally walking over
the [ __ ] bridge right when in Cologne
Germany as I mentioned was one of the
most bomb cities in World War two so
there's not a lot of old stuff there
because it just got destroyed but they
have this one beautiful Church right so
we're walking over the bridge and firs E
is going like do look at that building
man it's a beautiful building and that
building beautiful and I'm looking at is
these cluster whatever building said in
the middle of it is this amazing Church
so I'm looking at the building's going
what the [ __ ] is this guy seeing what
building was that building right there
look it's [ __ ] the architectures
beautiful it finally figured I was like
dude are you talking about the [ __ ]
Church
he said yeah that oh no I already told
this story told a story on Thursday I'm
still giving him [ __ ] about that it's a
great building all right
oh by the way virzi Rosie two Sicilian
and Greek he loved the Vienna schnitzel
- and he's actually really enjoying
Germany - which made me happy because
sometimes those Mediterranean guys you
know they get all [ __ ] upset about
the food and there's no sunshine and
[ __ ] you know but he's been having a
great time
all right gypsies hey there Billy
bloated brats I go to Romania oh this is
I was talking about learning that gypsy
is considered a racial slur all right
listen to this first sentence he goes I
go to Romania frequently for work and
I'm quite versed in gypsies and why it
is a racial slur you know what I love
about that was he still used the word
gypsy that's like if I was in America
being like hey everybody but when you
travel to America I've been to East st.
Louis and I'm quite versed in and words
and why it's a racial slur like I
wouldn't do that that's kind of what he
just did there first
Rome Romanians are not gypsies Roman
people Romanian people are descendants
of Romans I didn't know that gypsies are
people that came from Egypt if you want
to win the salt a Romanian person called
him a gypsy gypsy stick to themselves
and rob / steal from outsiders they will
fight at the drop of a hat I saw two old
lady gypsies fighting over which corner
they were selling flowers on in the old
city in Bucharest
I hope this clears it up a little no it
didn't that didn't clear anything up now
I know that Romanians are Roman and
gypsies our people are from Egypt I do
know that and then you went on to
[ __ ] trash him in a way that I'm sure
they were upset about I don't know Jesus
Christ did I just get in trouble just by
[ __ ] read that so they got a lot of
fight tomorrow what are you gonna do
I mean we I've seen you know with his
videos of to stamp people dressed up
like Santa Claus beating the [ __ ] out of
each other in my country all right but I
didn't realize that Romanians but almost
it says Roman in there huh
did not know that all right I love to
look a lot of that up double check which
means I'm not gonna do it I'll forget
about it and then the information you
just told me will be in my head in one
day I'm gonna spew it out but I'm
probably gonna get in trouble
alright recent breakup am I the [ __ ]
well personally first of all first alee
what two words that I just first of all
and certainly I don't know what the [ __ ]
I've known her anyways my girlfriend of
three years broke up with me over
something me and my family thinks is
stupid alright so right now I'm a little
nervous here you know your family's
backing you you know you're not one of
those [ __ ] young kids that can do no
wrong are you anyways we are both 20 and
since last February we've been so what
generation are you is that Generation Z
we are both 20 and since last February
we've been arguing since we invited her
to my birthday dinner and she got upset
because she was expected to pay for her
own meal all right
who who Mike who's who's her is that
your girlfriend okay I didn't tell my
parents until months later because I
didn't want to start anything any way
around early December my family asked me
to invite her to come up with us to my
dad's parents home on the 29th because
that's when we could celebrate Christmas
with them when I texted her she said am
I going to have to pay for my own gas I
have a SD I don't know what that means
so I assumed I was missing something so
I do do you have like a DD to the point
that you don't have the [ __ ] time to
write a DD we're not gonna look up
[ __ ] ate a SD All Saints disease a SD
you are not connected to the unit you
are not a winner all right I don't know
what the [ __ ] that is
I don't give a [ __ ] I'll learn about it
later
I have ASD so I soon I was missing
something so I asked my dad and he said
of course she flipped out about it I was
at ass burgers disease would that be a B
D was that anti-lock brakes I don't
[ __ ] know that's a B yes she flipped
out about it and became and it became
the new thing we could argue about her
mom her sister agree with her that it's
shitty to not pay for someone's gas when
you invite them someplace but my dad's
parents didn't pay for our gas but no
one we know asked for that and all of
our family members we invite to be Day
dinners never complain about paying
their own bill should I put pun not
intended I'd appreciate your advice sir
I'm a big fan you seemed pretty good
with your response in most cases I
should note that after breaking up with
me on New Year's despite all right
that's how he ended it I don't
understand what's going on it you guys
sound like a bunch of cheap [ __ ]
[ __ ] Green us with you he takes
somebody out for their [ __ ] birthday
you make him pay for their birthday
dinner that's [ __ ] terrible it's so
terrible it's like it's hilarious
and I'm sure she didn't give a [ __ ]
about paying for a gas she's probably
alluding to the fact that you did you
made her pay for her own [ __ ]
birthday that's [ __ ] hilarious then
in a lot of ways is sadder than going
out to dinner by yourself for your
birthday cuz at least nobody there at
the restaurant knows that your birthday
now you're sitting there with the table
full of people that know it's your
birthday and now you got to kick in Wow
yeah I should probably stop short of
calling you and your whole family a
bunch of cheap [ __ ] but let's just say
you're a little rough around the edges
but whatever that's water under the
bridge I guess you need to find your
soul mate the kind of woman that doesn't
mind paying for our own birthday
dinner well you know what maybe you're a
feminist you know because most guys we
pay for our own [ __ ] on our birthdays we
have to go out and go buy the big
[ __ ] fancy gift on Valentine's Day I
don't know I can't figure that one out
and the fact that you stopped
mid-sentence like she [ __ ] showed up
your place and club you to death and
then hit Send
so the forensics couldn't figure out
what time you died well he did send an
email all right lesbian dating with no
spark all right well whatever the [ __ ]
you're dating if there's no spark get
out of it
hey Bill I was wondering if you and I
could give me some dating advice to a
lady listener well unfortunately Mia's
not here
so you're gonna have to deal with my
dumb [ __ ] ideas I've been I've got
out on seven really good dates with a
wonderful woman
it was essentially everything I've ever
looked for in a partner she's hilarious
witty playful beautiful smart and
motivated and good kind-hearted person
are you [ __ ] my wife sorry the way we
have ridiculous witty banter reminds me
of how you and Nia are on the podcast
well that's what reminded me when you
said it it turns out we even want all
the same things in life in terms of a
long-term relationship oh how does this
go left she finally get her naked and
she had a dick I mean what is what is
going on here wanting a family living
close to parents and siblings in the
same area we grew up however in the past
few days she's grown a little distant of
Jesus when I asked her why she explained
that although she really enjoys spending
time with me and then I've done nothing
wrong
she's never felt strong passionate
feelings toward me okay this is how you
gotta walk somebody through their
feelings oh good this is never fun I
responded honestly they have not
necessarily felt that huge passive spark
oh wait a minute I read it run Oh
she said she never felt strong
passionate feelings toward me oh I
thought you meant she's never felt that
before and she was scared that she loved
you so she's saying like you're cool but
I'm not feeling I responded honestly
that I have not necessarily felt that
huge past annex Park with her either
well congratulations what you guys have
on your hands is your [ __ ] buddies okay
and now we're in an area of limbo and we
don't really know where to go from here
I think it's clear that we are attracted
to each other and very compatible but
there is a lack of clear chemistry
between us
she has an accelerated online class for
the next two weeks so we decided to cool
things down and meet again after that is
finished I think that's very wise my
question is if you consider an emotional
passionate drive necessarily necessary
for two people to be together
successfully long-term and how it was
with you and Nia I am personally a
believer in long-term love growing over
time and that for passionate love in my
experience generally follows the
Newtonian rule of what comes up must
always come down lovely wishes to you
Nia and then your little one and go [ __ ]
yourself I think that the fact that you
guys both had that really mature
conversation either one of you feeling a
spark it's just like you know in the
beginning if there's the spark there's
that that's that euphoria that you kind
of chase for the rest of your
relationship because you know you just
get used to each other and then when the
love comes out it's usually vacation
holiday or if you've been through
something together and you survived it
it brings you closer together
and then you have like these memories
you know like I've gone through rough
periods you know with my wife and like
having a kid just upsets the whole
applecart
and you focusing so much on the kid that
you can kind of like forget to check in
with each other and you know so what
I've learned with her is we have to take
like these little weekend vacations you
know in town just go to a hotel and it's
hilarious
then we instantly fall back in love
again and then spend the rest of the
time looking at pictures of our daughter
seeing how we miss her and stuff so I
don't know I think because you guys have
you guys seem like you should be really
good friends but the weird thing is you
already bagged or whatever so I don't
know how that works in the lesbian world
but I know in the hetero world that can
get weird and it's kind of 50/50
sometimes the guy gets weird sometimes
the woman gets weird it's just kind of
weird so I don't know I think it's
probably a good thing that you guys
aren't gonna see each other for a couple
of weeks and you can kind of be like you
know because it's early on just see
where the [ __ ] you are after two weeks
but um I don't know I think you're doing
it right not like I know anything about
that [ __ ] you know which is why you
probably hasn't eh I'm into to be honest
with you the only way that it's gonna
[ __ ] work is is if you do have that
spark in the beginning because that
sparks is what's gonna make you stay
because if you don't have that spark and
you get married for other [ __ ]
reasons or whatever then it's just like
you know you see if people marry for
money and they're sitting on a [ __ ]
yacht and they're miserable
alright grown man sitting while pissing
oh Jesus Christ
one of the worst images I've ever heard
dear old Billy blue hills I'm a 40 year
old man with three young children I
realized the other day that over the
past couple years I've been sitting down
when I piss
more often than not alright now this is
funny cuz if you're doing it because
you're tired it's just [ __ ] hilarious
I was worried that you're gonna this is
be some other progressive thing that you
know standing piss privileged whatever
the [ __ ] they're gonna come up with next
it all started when the kids were babies
my wife would wake up to feed and I
would head down to the can like a zombie
to piss and I was too damn tired to
stand and aim now the kids are a little
older and I'm still [ __ ] exhausted
most of the time at home that I find
myself sitting down to piss all the time
I think I'm just tired as [ __ ] and my
crazy to assume this is common among
thing among men my age with young
children now that you are 50 you do the
same I can't be the only one right
thanks love the podcast and go [ __ ]
yourself no I don't do that the only
time I ever do that is if my wife's
sleeping and when we lived in smaller
apartments I didn't want to wake her up
when I was taking a piss you know out of
consideration I would sit down and I
would always make me laugh and I would
always picture all of my friends making
fun of me that I was sitting down well
well pissing I think the fact that you
still say pissing rather than peeing
which is one of my major pet peeves I he
me what a guy says I have to go pee it's
just I can't even tell you my body like
microscopically like contorts oh by the
way somebody told me it's anyway and not
anyways and I have to tell you I don't
give a [ __ ] I like saying anyways I say
in the plural sense though you're
probably not the only one who does it
but I will tell you that what I have
learned just having one kid is how
important it is to get eight hours of
really good sleep and you shouldn't
watch TV and be on your [ __ ] phone
I've actually gone back to reading if he
consider reading sports books reading I
try to read but my wife she always
watches the [ __ ] Real Housewives on
that tattoo parlor show and you know any
show that involves people she doesn't
care about screaming at each other for
some reason she loves to watch that
before she goes to bed
so I just put on these no let the
[ __ ] same headphones I wear when I
fly in a plane so I can't hear people
and I just read the [ __ ] book but
anyways I think maybe if you get eight
hours sleep you know he hit the gym a
little bit if you have time but I I know
how tired I am with one kid I can't
imagine with like three and a good
friend of my life told me one time when
he was talking about being a parent his
kids are older he's got like two or
three kids and three kids and he said he
goes dude he goes I've been tired since
the 90s so I think that's just what it
is that's just what it is you know what
it is cuz once your kids get older they
could kind of take care of themselves
meaning they can wake up brush their
teeth get ready for school at all that
you feel like you're not gonna be as
tired but I think the thing that makes
you tired it's the worry because you
constantly [ __ ] worrying that
something's gonna happen don't but
whatever all right that's the podcast
apologize for the low volume of talking
hair I really want to thank everybody
that's come out to my shows here in
Germany I could not have had a better
time it was [ __ ] awesome and I will
definitely be back the next time
hopefully when I get a new hour you guys
still want to come to see me I will
definitely be back I think I'll come
during the summer months next time or
Oktoberfest one or the other all right
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
you Thursday